die meisten von euch wollten wissen
welches Londoner Hotel wir genommen
haben und ich fand es so gruselig durch
diesen Flo zu gehen denn das Zimmer war
wirklich ganz am Ende des Flurs es war
echt total sauber und wir sind schon das
zweite Mal hier es ist nicht sehr groß
aber von der Preiskategorie her ganz
normal für Londoner Verhältnisse ihr
dürft auf keinen Fall vergessen den
richtigen Stecker mitzunehmen denn hier
sind die Steckdosen ganz anders als bei
uns die Unterkunft lag mitten in white
Chapel ein Stadtteil der eigentlich eine
sehr hohe Kriminalitätsrate haben soll
wir haben natürlich hier und da mal was
gemerkt aber wir wurden jetzt irgendwie
nicht beklaut oder sowas ich war abends
richtig Müdigkeit besoffen wollte aber
unbedingt noch raus und einfach die
Stadt erleben habe ich dann Profils für
mich entdeckt also Croissant und Waffel
in Kombination das war so lecker das
muss ich unbedingt mal nachmachen
vorbeigekommen wenn der Scheibe einfach
steht und irgendwie feiere ich diese Art
der Kommunikation weil bei uns ist es
auch so wenn die Cheesecakes ausverkauft
sind dann kann man da nicht einfach
irgendwas auftauen und anbieten das wird
ja alles frisch gemacht und wenn der
anderen groß ist dann ist das halt
einfach so wenn ihr meine Fuss nicht
verpassen möchte dann das jetzt gerne
einen Kommentar da